you took took way too long man we're at
the end of the podcast now everyone also
everyone else called in country over
Gilbert hold on time everyone called on
time I know it's you I remember my
brother we grew up there but Theo thanks
for calling it I love you so much you
know that brother but not that we're
going to continue to do stuff together
you're the best to get the good night
smile Bobbie smile for the camera owners
you know what I'm really impressed by
how well this actually went it was great
you're right
no I'm I thought for sure that nine out
of ten phone calls would fail but it
didn't only Theo's did yeah he was
probably just doing uh doing a set so it
took a little while to get the text
you'll probably get some more calls
throughout the night
now there's one I told him to cancel it
so
happy birthday Bobby didn't even get a
thank you
we're like two hours of scrambling to
get all these numbers
[Music]